So I will now extend this code
to create a three-dimensional plot.
Okay, I'm going to collapse this
create a new section.
And this will be called.
vectors in 3D
So I've introducing to this code because we're going to
later use this for more advanced examples.
Okay.
Let me just copy the code.
So these are the same functions we
saw before but for three dimensions.
same as before, but now we have a z Axis or a
You know a linear space for the points along the
Z axis.
And of course, we're now adding a third.
list in this Tuple
to the points on
The three axes so same function just adapted
for three dimensions.
and if I want to create
one vector in this three-dimensional
just coordinate system.
So for example 10 on the X and Y
and Z axis would get something that looks like.
Like this, let me copy the figure information.
right
So this is the x-axis.
You can see if we look at it from the x-axis.
If I follow this Gray Line go all
the way here.
It is 10 points away from
the 10.
from the x-axis
case maybe here
then on the y-axis same thing.
on the y-axis
And of course the Z axis.
So you can have to imagine this is in a
three-dimensional space.
right
And of course we can probably second one.
Let's change this to.
20 on the z-axis, for example
So going forward we're going to use this code to draw.
vectors needed two or three dimensions
Okay. So the orange one obvious second Vector is higher.
And now this one goes up to 15. So let's make
these point on the z-axis 15.
Okay, so going forward we're going to use this source code.
Now, let me show you.
practical example
But now with vector addition because I think
outside of outside of physics. I can't come up with any
practical example, so I'm just going
to turn our attention to
the polar coordinate system
We will talk about the polar coordinate system.
the magnitude of a vector
and then once we have the the magnitude we will also look
at
scalar multiplication
And then once we've covered these three, yeah, so
the polar coordinate system magnitude of
a vector scale of multiplication and then we can
Implement cosine similar. It would be cool to plot the
rotate space. Yeah what there's a
greater library, but not math plot that
math problem is flat if you want to interactive one. There's something called.
I think Seaborn does it
but there's also one called plot the I really like I really like this Library.
So if I could apply for python
Let me just Google pull probably 3D.
plot
It's a very simple to use Library when it comes in JavaScript. So
You know, you can create. Yeah, this is the one.
This is very cool. We can take snapshots of it.
You take that's a snapshot.
You can zoom in pan.
And maybe I'll give you the source code for using this Library. It's pretty
straightforward by them. Nothing spectacles. It's very analogous to
matplotlib
so the same convention, you know.
You well this well, you need a daily frame. So this is
going to be the list of values and then so DF stands for data frame
and the data frame is simply a table.
X and Y points. So the left column would be the X points. Why
kind of would be the white points?
Yeah, and you can also have you know, like
a
He density.
It's a bit finicky to play around but this is this is one option.